uh what is something who who was rapping
first you were Savage like when you guys
were did he because he obviously kind of
got a head head start with you on the
career-wise but like did you guys kind
of start around the same time well
oh [__] I don't know
I'm saying it's true it was close
I don't know he probably ran before me
forever yeah yeah I'd say it's true I
don't know
do you feel like seeing him like uh I
feel like he's done such a good job of
just like leveling up in terms of just
skill wise like
I just feel like every time I hear a new
Sabbath first I'm just like what the
[__] like no you guys got any sort of
friendly competition when you guys are
in the studio together
no I won't do no [__] like that we
really should go on that [__]
just do we probably do either of you
write stuff down or are you doing off
the head oh yeah [__] out of here this
[__] out of here
so when you rap it's all off the head oh
[__]
do you do the melody then punch in no
what you mean like like how to be mine
yeah you might like hum the uh yeah
[Music]
no man I had my time when I'm punching I
had my time when I my my normal time
I'ma flow all the way through you know
what I'm saying oh just for real like
yeah I just go all the way through and
then clean it up then I go back down
through the guy now after I do the ad
little [__] I just let the engineer go
try to find a who cause I'm in between
that [__] so you'll lay down for the
most part A one take all the way through
yeah yeah
off the top if I feel like I ain't
[__] up damn
that's right give me the right floor how
I want to make sure I don't [__] up
while I'm going
yeah yeah that shit's crazy man it
should be
that should be easy sometimes forever
are you like it does feel like the rap
[__] is easy for you do you uh challenge
yourself doing trying to like learn the
other new [__] like you're trying to
[__]
um
[__] they're laughing bro I just said
they were trying to um
I don't know how to write a rap and like
read it and wrap it you know what I'm
saying like I don't know how to do that
because you'll sound like you're reading
yeah it sounds like like I can't really
like make it it's not natural it ain't
natural and in my mind to be sitting up
I don't [__] that I can't so you like
you don't ever write an idea down at
least oh no I don't hell no you don't
have any ideas
you
got an idea to put a snake on a [__]
dinner table for the album cover that's
a [__] idea
I go out the beat I have the beat sound
the beat the beat tell me what I need to
do you ever thought of a line like one
line to be like oh I gotta use that
um
no
damn
it's very very very
um
prolific of you as a writer as a
non-writer even oh I just go in the
studio in Nigeria I don't know black out
yeah basically I turned into a rap I
mean you are a rapper yeah yeah yeah and
that [__] would you act
like in a movie like Jack Harlow just
dropped a movie would you act oh they're
not already were you acting in oh I act
like a rapper
I see what you did there yeah and also
apparently a part-time comedian
oh [__]
oh man shout out to you
yeah
get me off a little bit yeah
just a little bit man